We need to stay focused on what really matters: baseball.
Listen, grasshoppers.
There's no crying in baseball.
Because if you start, you'll never stop.
You're gonna strike out and you're gonna lose,...
...and you're gonna get cut from the team.
Or even worse, you're gonna make the team but who cares?
It's the lacrosse team.
Don't be ashamed.
Failure happens to the best of us.
But life is about getting up, dusting yourself off, pounding an energy drink,...
...hitting homers, running through walls, making the show, winning the World Series...
...and touring Canada as a DJ.
Because the best bounce back up and do this.
So go ahead and cry, but make sure they're tears of joy.
Because baseball is better.
Baseball is better.